48 hours of sharing new details about
the investigation into a college
student's murder 21 year old ali costell
was about to get ready for her senior
year at the university of mississippi
when she was found dead a search of her
apartment led investigators to her apple
watch and key evidence that pointed to a
suspect cbs saturday morning co-host
michelle miller reports for 48 hours
when investigators looking at ali's
apple watch discovered that her last
text messages were with fellow student
brandon thiesfeld lafette county
sheriff's investigator jared bendren
says they wanted him to come in to talk
and soon
he said that he would be there at 8 30
monday morning an 8 30 monday morning
came
no brandon bundren says that's when the
decision was made to start tracking his
phone what did you find out
that he was on interstate 55 headed
north toward memphis
district attorney ben creekmore says
with fiesfeld appearing to be on the run
investigators got an affidavit of arrest
for murder and immediately sent out a
bulletin when we saw that his truck was
leaving oxford there was a bolo for his
tag
it didn't take long for the memphis
fugitive task force to spot thieves fell
about an hour and a half two hours later
they caught him at the gas station
he had a 40 caliber gun consistent with
the caliber of the shell casings that
were found on the scene
and he had blood on him
[Applause]
you can see michelle miller's report
what ally costell didn't know tonight at
8 eastern 7th central on the cbs news
streaming network